Hello.
Nice one.
Yeah but, today I've got a gun,
and I'm gonna shoot through
these water balloons.
This is FPS England.
Yeah, not quite as good,
but these are full of water,
hopefully we'll get to see the pellet
go from one to the other.
Yeah, I wonder if you'll actually see
it slow down as it goes through each one.
I don't think you'd actually
be able to hit each one,
chances are slim.
I dunno, I reckon I've got the talent,
all it needs to get these water balloons.
He is in the army.
And this is actually a failed experiment,
we did this about a year ago
and this happened.
Ready?
Yeah.
Oh no way! no way!
so good shot.
Oh cheers, yeah
Brilliant
I did get wet.
Balloon were bigger at that time though,
So I think we'll have more luck this time.
Okay. Let's see what happens.
Okay, Ready?
Yeah.
Sweet - Nice - Awesome
That's pretty cool.
Is that full speed?
Yeah.
It looks it's still really fast.
Jeez that's really fast isn't it.
Well, that was actually a lot cooler
than I thought it'd be.
That's actually a really powerful gun,
I'm quite scared of it.
It's quite impressive.
Yeah, yeah I get it.
But the bullet was really fast.
Yeah, we can see it
slow down through.Yeah.
Bigger balloons, higher frame rate.
We're shooting this at a very
weird resolution at 7,500
frames a second, which is?
300 times slower.
Hopefully we'll see a
bit more. Let's do it.
Might slow down in the balloons as well.
Yeah.
That's what that's What noise
is going to make is that
That's what going to happen there.
Whoa!
Didn't even go through it.
I love having all these
videos. All you get wet.
So that four seconds that we just shot
is now 24 minutes of playback.
That's impressive.Alright.
Oh it bounced off.
So the big balloons were too much
for that small pallet to get through.
too strong I think?
Bounced right off that.
I like that it went through both balloons,
but then it slowed down
just right to be bouncing off it.
Yeah
Must have slowed down
so much. it's just got,
So technically this balloon
has deflected an air pistol pellet.
Impressive.
but we've got two balloons here.
We've got to get rid of them somehow.
So I'm thinking some sort of
movie style diving gunshot.
I ain't done so I approve definitely.
Yeah
Don't fire until both your
feet are off the ground.
I want it to be like diving
like this don't half ass it because
Okay
If you're a bitch about it
you're a bitch for a long time on here.
Ready?
Okay
Ready? - Yeah
Yeah - Yeah
That's actually really good.
That's proper effort into that.
I love that.
I'm happy with that.